the new Wednesday Addams series is a
huge hit and loaded with kooky and
spooky Easter eggs to the 90s movies and
original sitcom yupikai movie lovers I'm
Jan and I've been re-watching and
pausing Wednesday to uncover all the
weirdest little details you might have
missed the series begins with Wednesday
going to regular school where she finds
her brother Pugsley trust up with an
apple stuffed in his mouth mirroring how
he was introduced in the 1991 Adams
Family movie where Wednesday had him
tied up for archery practice Tim Burton
directs a new series and there are
numerous references to his movies
throughout the show if you stop and zoom
in on principal weem's desk there's a
little dried up head under a glass Dome
a nod to Harry the hunter shrunken head
from Beetlejuice and the giant bear in
the principal's office is a callback to
the enormous stuffed bear in The Adams
Family home from the 60s TV show when
Wednesday ends up in the infirmary after
the gargoyle incident she lies in the
bed with her arms crossed as if she were
in a coffin which is also how she went
to sleep in the first movie after
Wednesday meets Tyler for the first time
she explained she knows how to fix his
broken coffee machine as she has a
device with a similar mechanism at home
steam-powered Guillotine I built it when
I was 10. I wanted to decapitate my
dolls more efficiently this is a
throwback to the guillotine scene in
Adam's Family Values where Wednesday and
Pugsley attempt to reenact the beheading
of Marie Antoinette on their baby
brother death to the enemies of the
people of the Republic
and Wednesday's mention of decapitating
her dolls is a nod to both the sitcom
where she had a doll with a severed head
and also the 90s movie the Show tips its
hat to the classic Adams Family theme
tune from the 60s show in the first
episode when Tyler tells Wednesday maybe
that's scary you just kind of kooky and
she replies I prefer spooky the clue to
unlocking the secret entrance to the
Nightshade society's basement is to snap
twice
another Easter egg to the theme tune
from the original sitcom Wednesdays
dancing at the Nevermore Raven has
already become a much-loved moment with
Jenna Ortega revealing that she
choreographed the whole routine herself
she also confirmed my suspicions that
some of her moves were a homage to the
dance performed by Lisa Loring in the
original sitcom where she does a side
shuffle with her hands and with her feet
then if you learn how to dance well
she'll think your boss
Ortega also said she took some
inspiration from the rich man's frog
dance craze that featured in Bob fosse's
musical sweet charity later at the dance
Lucas and his mates drench everyone with
red paint in a nod to Stephen King's
carry were a group of Mean Girls shower
Carrie with a bucket of pig's blood
something that Wednesday herself
references they couldn't even spring for
real Pig's blood it's only pink when
Xavier asks Wednesday if she's ever shot
a bow and arrow she replies online live
targets which is a call back to Adam's
Family Values when Wednesday and Pugsley
were lining up for archery practice and
her brother shot down a live bird it's
an American bald eagle but aren't they
extinct they are now among the many
taxidermied mice and animals at uriah's
Heap there are several Easter eggs to
Tim Burton's films I spotted this one of
a dead rodent in a wedding dress a
reference to Corpse Bride I also saw
this Freddy Krueger creature with The
Nightmare on Elm Street villain's iconic
red striped top Fedora and blades for
hands like Freddy Krueger who
infiltrates and attacks his victims in
their dreams the hide also attacks
Xavier during one of his Visions this
creature's been haunting my dreams for
the past couple weeks when I was
painting this one the claws reached out
of the canvas and took a swipe at me
until I got these scratches it stopped
to kimbot who creates the dressed up
Taxidermy rodents and among the many she
has at home is one that's dressed as
Beetlejuice plus there's another Freddy
Krueger one as well when Wednesday goes
to find Tyler at the Weathervane she
rings a bell and after he comes out he
says
we rang this is a nod to The Adams
Family servant Lurch and the recurring
gag where the family would ring an
enormous gong to summon him
[Music]
yes luge and when Tyler wonders whether
Wednesday was ever a girl scout she
replies I can eat Girl Scouts for
breakfast this is a funny reference to
The Addams Family movie and Wednesday's
reaction when Amanda asked if she or
Pugsley wanted to buy any of her Girl
Scout cookies I'll buy a cup if you buy
a box of my delicious Girl Scout cookies
do we have a deal or they made some real
girl scouts when Wednesday breaks into
the old meeting house she comes across
an old painting of crack Stone and
notices a woman on the left looking out
towards her when the camera Cuts in for
a close-up it appears to be goody Adams
Wednesday's ancestor however if you
compare this with the woman in the wide
shot of the painting they aren't the
same person I can't be sure this isn't a
continuity error but I suspect it could
well be a deliberate decision to give
the sense that the painting is alive or
that Goody's ghost is communicating
through it to Wednesday after Wednesday
discovers a truth about crackstone's
evil past she and conspire to burn down
the statue of the evil Pilgrim and this
feels a lot like a nod to Adam's Family
Values where Wednesday instigated a
revolt against the camp and her gang
burned down the pilgrim set I've decided
to scalp you and burn your village To
The Ground by the way when crackstone's
statue begins to melt it's a neat bit of
foreshadowing for how he burns up in the
finale Morticia pulling the flower head
off a red rose in front of Garrett
Gates's grave is a shout out to the
opening titles of the 60s sitcom and to
the 90s movie where she cuts the heads
off the Roses she's picking and there
was another hat tip to that movie when
we discover via the yearbook that
Morticia attended Nevermore in 1991. the
same year The Adams Family movie was
released on her way to Nevermore if you
pause you can see the suitably named
Adams Family license plate which also
reveals they live in New Jersey a homage
to Charles Adams who drew the original
cartoons and was born in the Garden
State after Gomez is arrested for murder
he has to change into prison uniform
which has the number
171912 on it an Easter egg to the date
and year that Charles Adams was born
January the 7th 1912. Wednesday was her
trademark black dress and white collar
from her previous incarnations however
Nevermore she has to wear a school
uniform but only ever dresses in black
and white unlike everyone else and by
the end she prepares to leave Nevermore
she's back in her signature outfit now
Adam's Family fans won't have missed the
painting of it in the basement of The
Nightshade Society however if you pause
here and zoom in we discover his full
name was Ignatius it and he was known as
Supreme shade although is no longer
alive the way the show focuses on this
painting feels like a hint that we might
see one of his descendants appear in
season two principal weem's costume was
influenced by Tippy hedron's look in
Hitchcock's classic movie The Birds And
you can see this especially in her
overall appearance including her
hairstyle at the Harvest Festival it's
particularly appropriate given the
overwhelming Raven imagery at Nevermore
the bird on the principal's desk and
also the fact that Wednesday's dark
foreboding Visions Placer at the Raven
end of the spectrum of psychic abilities
you're a raven your Visions are more
potent more powerful all this avian
imagery including the Raven dance and
the name of the school itself is also a
huge shout out to Edgar Allan Poe's
famous poem The Raven whose talking bird
repeatedly says the word Nevermore now
given the homage already to Hitchcock I
think Wednesday's ever so slight smile
at the very end of the first episode is
a nod to Norman Bay creates his Infamous
little smile at the end of Psycho when
Tyler sets up a movie night date with
Wednesday and crack Stone's Crypt and he
puts on Legally Blonde you can see
Wednesday wincing and discomfort from
the movie Tyler probably knew she
wouldn't like it so this is a subtle red
flag and clue that his intentions
towards her aren't good as we discover
by the end and I also think the moment
is a little call back to Adam's Family
Values when Gary and Becky Force
Wednesday Pugsley and Joel to watch
Disney movies to try and force them to
be happy The Little Mermaid stop it he's
only a child so I already covered a lot
of the clues about why Miss Thornhill
would turn out to be the secret villain
in my Clues you missed video but what I
didn't mention was the one where
Thornhill says to the myrrh you always
tucked into that little back Booth when
I come in for my daily matcha latte but
then when she meets Tyler at the Raven
he says she comes in every day for a
cappuccino double cab no foam two pumps
of sugar-free vanilla and hair AI
telegraph's a fact she's up to something
it's a small town it's hard to keep
secrets when Wednesday goes to see her
therapists the creators of the new show
Miles Miller and Alfred Goff get a shout
out as real estate agents and the two
names below Tommy Harper and Natalie
tester are producers on the series the
season ends on a big Cliffhanger where
Wednesday discovers she has a new threat
to contend with but I'm really wondering
how her stalker got her cell phone
number in the first place one
possibility is that Xavier's got her
number already someone installed some
malware on his phone and now this hacker
could even spy on conversations between
the pair but if Xavier had installed
nordvpn the sponsor of this video that
threat would have been easily
neutralized thanks to its Advanced
threat protection features nor does a
lot more than just a VPN if you
accidentally stumble across a shady site
or a fishing link that downloads a virus
to your device Nord will delete the
malicious software immediately and if
you're using public Wi-Fi if I like in a
coffee shop you're especially at risk
from snoopers who can break into your
connection and access any personal data
being transmitted so using a quality VPN
like Nord on your mobile devices will
make sure you're protected against these
threats at home Nord will also keep your
browsing private by preventing your
internet service provider from tracking
what websites you're visiting Nord will
also block those annoying and intrusive
ads making your online experience a lot
safer cleaner and enjoyable for a
limited time all our viewers can grab an
exclusive offer on a two-year plan with
a huge discount plus four bonus months
completely free just visit nordvpn.com
flicks or go to the link in the video
description to get the offer or use
coupon code flicks when you check out
there are some more great details and
clues hidden in season one to the big
villain twist like the Frankenstein book
Miss Thornhill gave Wednesday and her
deadly Carnival plants which I talk a
lot more about in my other the Wednesday
video you can tap here to watch that
plus there's a link in the video
description so what was your favorite
moment in Wednesday and do you have any
predictions for what could happen in
season two let me know your thoughts and
theories in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video do leave a thumbs
up I really appreciate it thanks for
enjoying Wednesday with me and hope you
have a marvelous movie living week
yippee Kai movie lovers